- Seeing your son in
such a dangerous position,
obviously, any parent
would fight
to protect their kid
at all costs.
(police sirens)
- "Defending Jacob" tells
the story of a prosecutor
whose 14-year-old son is charged
with the murder
of a classmate.
- We have some bad news.
The print we lifted from
the victim's sweatshirt...
is from your son.
- Wait-- What?
- It's tricky when you're trying
to create a mini-series
'cause you wanna make sure each episode
has a strong engine and a purpose.
- There's gotta be an explanation.
- I didn't do it. I swear.
- We begin to see this family tested,
and she begins to
question everything.
- Do you have any doubts
about Jacob's innocence?
- No, of course not.
- It's all about the family,
how they experience it.
- The foundation is rocked.
There's a lot of trust issues,
a lot of guilt.
It kind of opens
all those doors.
(thunder crashes)
- Is there a part of you...
thinks he might've done it?
- How well can you ever know anyone?
And I think this show
forces us to think about
those boundaries that exist
with the people we love.
- Once you open Pandora's box
it's those scary corners
you don't want to explore.
- The twists and turns of the thriller
are fantastic,
but it's this crisis of
parenting that makes it unique.
- What are you willing to do
as a family?
How well do we know
our children?
How far are we willing to go?
- The interesting thing about
this show
is that it's not shot
as a TV show,
it's shot like an 8-hour movie.
- I know you think you know Jacob,
but you don't.
- Did he do this?
There's a cliffhanger every episode.
- I can't find a move.
- It's because you don't have one.
- Jacob. How's he doing?
Whoa, whoa!
- You think this is a joke?
- I can't play this game anymore.
- Did you do it?